The next source of error,
inconsistent data across locations,
should not come as a surprise.
This is the interoperability issue we've
been discussing throughout the course.
Where multiple physicians are involved,
it can be further complicated
by differences in the way they document
even the same clinical issues.
Particularly when text
entry is involved.
For example, they might use different
terms for the same thing, or
nonstandard abbreviations or acronyms.
Similarly, physicians may not record
all the needed data leading to
misinterpretations of the past history,
or even the current treatments.
Finally, where multiple locations
are involved in patient's care,
it may not be clear which
of several observations or
events is definitive or
even the most up-to-date